première mesure le recours au chômage
partiel face à la réduction l arrêt
obligatoire de l'activité de votre
entreprise vous pouvez demander de
placer vos salariés en activité
partielle
en clair l'état prend en charge le
paiement des horaires non travaillés et
à hauteur de 84 % du salaire net
jusqu'à la limite de 4,5 smic dans les
yvelines d'après les premières tendances
de la direccte entre le 1er janvier et
le 24 mars 2020 près de 1300 entreprises
ont déposé une demande que ça concerne
environ trente deux mille salariés et
pour comparaison sur la même période en
2010 9 78 société avait fait la demande
pour 12000 personnes à propos de ce
dispositif vous pouvez contacter la
direccte ile de france ou retrouver des
informations sur son site internet
deuxième disposition le report du
paiement des cotisations sociales et des
impôts des entreprises
une demande a réalisé auprès de l'urssaf
ou sur le site internet impots.gouv.fr
autres mesures la mise en place d'une
garantie de crédit c'est à dire que
l'état peut se porter garant d'un crédit
pour une entreprise
acteur majeur de ce dispositif la bpi
france informations à retrouver aussi
sur son site internet
et il ya aussi la possibilité de ré
échelonner son crédit en cours avec la
médiation du crédit
enfin quatrième dispositif à destination
des petites entreprises des micro
entrepreneurs des indépendants ou encore
des professions libérales l'état met en
place une aide de 1500 euros pour des
structures ayant moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires ayant subi
une fermeture administrative et
connaissant une perte de chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 70% par rapport à
la même période l'an dernier